hey guys hopefully in hd today i'm going
to be able to show you guys how to get
the zoom
effect in cam studio screen recorder so
first of all um you're going to open the
link provided in the description i'm
going to just copy that so i can give it
back to you now and actually upload the
video
uh it's theworkerscollection.com
and this is called the magnifying glass
there is a pro version if you want to
buy it but i'm going to demonstrate how
to get the free version it's a very very
small download it's the it's only half a
megabyte so i'm just going to click on
it and hit open
and it's already done downloading so i'm
going to hit open again
and it's going to open windows explorer
where i can extract all these files so
first of all i'm going to exit out of
our internet browser since we
no longer need this
what i'm going to do is just hit the
extract all files button
and find a place that i want to extract
it so i'll go into my documents and i
made a file
just for program documents that i'm
downloading so i hit ok and make sure
you have this button checked to show
extracted files when complete
hit drag button
wait for this to finish copying just
five items less than a megabyte and that
is done so we have this
then all the extract files will be in
one folder hopefully
let's go ahead and look for that folder
right now and
it should be called setup set up magni
glass magnifying glass setup so i'm just
going to double click on setup and usc
pops up which is obviously invisible cam
studio but um if you have that disabled
it won't come up so this will install it
onto your computer
we're going to go through the typical
setup process hit next a ton of times
and it is done so i want to launch the
application when this is actually done
the finish button
and this is the magnifying glass um
application
so basically what we're going to do is
say we're going to run it at windows
startup
and we're going to show glass after the
application startup
and i'm going to obviously it's only
available in english and russian which
is interesting but i'm speaking english
and my hotkey
is going to be
control shift f3
just just actually no it's going to be
ctrl shift q
um
so it says if you're a hotkey
combination resetting when you enter
such a hotkey combination um
well that's basically important what i'm
going to say
is those two
go to basic options i'm going to say
full visible transparency for this is
for windows 2000 xp so it won't really
matter if you're in vista and zoom
factor i'll go ahead and say two and a
half
um
then we're going to we can set the size
of the actual zoom um i'm just going to
mess around with this here it's not
going to be a big difference
so that's what i'm going to use and
advanced options we can choose it to be
in contrast mode negative i'm sure
you've seen in all those picture effects
and also fixed gamma and broken tv also
use quite a bit of cpu so i'm going to
just say no
and
offset from cursor we don't want any
offset from cursor i'm going to lower
that actually i'm going to leave it at
the default just to see what it's like
um
it's pretty good
next what we want to do uh this is a pro
version so we really don't need to look
into that because we haven't actually
paid for the pro version
so that is all the options that we can
set so our hotkeys ctrl shift q
now anytime we want i'm going to just go
ahead and open
any random
my documents folder here ctrl shift q
and there you see it
it's a little bit offset for my cursor
which i might not actually like and so
i'm going to change i'm going to change
a few things
i'm going to
exit out
and down here in my system tray it's
magnifier so i'm going to go to options
again to bring up this menu at any time
um i wanted to
erase any offset from my cursor so it is
directly on top of my cursor
and i'm going to
decrease the zoom factor a little bit
and make it more
widescreen so let's see
360 by 240
i'm gonna go
i'm working right now on 360 by
no i'm recording in 640 by 360.
so i'm going to go ahead and make it a
100
100 by 200
for the sake of showing you guys so now
when i open something up uh let's see
open calculator and i want to show you
what button exactly i am pressing there
you go you see exactly what it is and in
the window
so um
that's just a quick way to get zoom in
cam studio you may have already seen my
tutorial about how to use your mouse to
get a much larger version although that
does make the screen blink if you just
turn completely white turn completely
black mess with your microphone but then
you can see quite vividly what exactly
i'm clicking on or the again the
built-in magnifying glass feature
into windows vista so um
yeah that's another way that you can
customize your magnifier in windows in
cam studio so i hope you like this
tutorial thanks for watching
and subscribe peace
you